ううっう0
今から日本語の講座を行います
そうです道元ってアレルギーとかないですか
ありますペニシリンです penicillin ですねはいわかりました
そうで同源ってアレルギーとかないですか
あり
をスペにしペニスっ
ペニスをペ2
pen 4ペニしペニスもう一度いいですか
今日はありがとうすごく楽しかった
ネットフィックスてやっぱ面白いねまたなるこそ一緒に見ようねうんまた近いうちに
遊びにきてね
イクイクおやすにキャーキャー今日はありがとう
すごく楽しかったネットフィックスてやっぱ面白いね
またなるコース
と一緒に見ようねうすぐに来てねんすぐに入ってすぐに久美子に会いたい
じゃあ戻ればいいの
8また次回という意味でもういっつも紛らわしい事を言うから
私本当はもう1回チリングをしたかったのにもう1回切り
すぐに会いに行くキュッ今日燃やす込みを出しだったな
道元燃やすごみってもう言わないかも
どーん
分かった燃えるゴミとかいや最近別の言い方が流行っていると別の言い方って
可燃ごみとか違う最近老眼ボールって言うんだ
道元すぐそういうこと言うから5名
巻いている
道元すぐそういうこと言うから
マイ店
山本さんの家ってどんな家
うちはマンションだよマンションすげーあ何が普通のマンションだ
普通のマンションって言ってみたいわ普通の家のほうがよくね
バージョンの方が広くていいじゃんモンソンの方が広い
四方に何にいるっ気今日もありがとうございました先生
多いさようならさようなら
今日もありがとねーすごく楽しかったよ
誰
今日もあり方ねよ星人と道議まいろう生です
はい山本皮膚科です今日はちょっと気になるほころがあるので見てもらいたいんですが
はいわかりました今日の午後ならまだ空いていますがこれそうですかはい山本皮膚科
です
今日はちょっと気になるモグラがあるので見てもらいたいんですが
土竜もぐらやこちらは皮膚かな
のでまだ小さくて黒いんですけど形がやっぱりちょっと心配で
がんだと思いますかモグラに元
歌おうすんごく綺麗だよ本当ありがとうと
うんすごく綺麗になったよきれいになった
ちょっとうんきれいになってきてる
me